hey everybody and welcome to a throbbing
wild ride with stevo can we say whoa we
got joey lawrence this week starve hit
shows like blossom and he's graced the
cover of every teeny bopper heartthrob
magazine there ever was man what a treat
it was to talk to this guy and i gotta
say to this day
he is
very good looking so maybe you want to
consume this content with a little bit
of privacy i'm just saying maybe you
just love privacy like i do maybe you
care about cyber security like i do
that's why i use nord vpn it's the
fastest virtual private network out
there and it costs barely what a cup of
coffee costs per month and i'm telling
you it prevents people from snooping
around in your bank details your
passwords taking your online identity
telling you the safety from nordvpn is
what i love especially when i'm
traveling and boy do i have a deal for
you if you go to nordvpn that's
n-o-r-d-vpn.com
stevo you get a huge discount plus a
free gift and it's totally risk-free
with nord vpn's 30-day money-back
guarantee absolutely no risk total cyber
security and you can treat yourself to
content from all around the world that
would otherwise be geo-blocked so head
over to
nordvpn.com to jump on this deal
and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
joey lawrence hey yeah thank you man the
original jlaw that's right
you're right about that you're right
about that that's funny how'd you come
up with that yeah man god said that
before uh you came in the man i said
dude i'm stealing that you do it it's
great it's true it really is you're the
original this is my 40th year of doing
this is that crazy wow
it's insane yeah i saw on your wikipedia
a year's active
1982
present right right my 40th year and
that's commercials you started doing
started commercials in new york when i
was a little kid and did uh like of
several of them that first year you know
i think we did like 60 national
commercials or something like that yeah
which is you know that's crazy right you
don't realize but uh and then it was one
of those classic things back when you
know the legends were still sort of
around us you know carson's guys saw
that and that was all over the tv you
know tylenol commercials and kool-aid
commercials all these things yeah and
they're like let's get this little kid
on you know and um i had to go audition
i had to go out to california they flew
me out from philadelphia it was where
i'm from and uh i was tapping i had been
tapping for like two years because i
loved the dance tap dancing time i was
like three and a half so when i was five
i was i could tap a little bit you know
i guess so this is where i'm saying he
ripped yeah well so they brought me so
they brought me out to california and uh
i'll never forget my mom flew out with
me and they put us up at the sheridan uh
which is still there that sheridan with
the orange neon that same hotel yeah
um then we use that for everybody uh
around jackass i'm sure yeah that's it's
still like the predominant hotel for
this area we dropped your bus off there
too when we we did that that was where
we did the put this podcast with danger
it was parked there yeah yeah yeah so i
and i went and auditioned at the old nbc
studios uh carson was in the room and ed
the quarter and his producer and
everyone was smoking in there i remember
that and it was like shag carpet and
they said what can you do so we had an
interview and they said what can you do
i said well i can tap and they said
great they said do i have my boombox
with me and my song prepared you know to
tap but there was carpeting
were you tapping to something you're
supposed to tap to or was it like well i
had prepared something my tap teacher
gave me like give my regards to broadway
oh gotcha yeah so are you too young to
be nervous at that point or i was not
nervous
yeah i had no idea really i mean he
looked like exactly like my grandfather
which he really did and he was cool and
i knew my parents said this is like this
is pretty cool so go in there and do
your best so i was just doing my best i
didn't really understand the magnitude
of what that was
but i told him i couldn't tap i said
listen i can't tap in here because
there's no there's no hard floors and
johnny was sitting behind this massive
desk true story and he said get on the
desk they cleared the desk off and he
picked me up and put me on the desk and
they press play and i guess i did a good
job because we walked out of there and
we literally got back to the hotel and
we went home and when we got home there
was an answering machine message from
brandon tardikov who was running nbc at
the time they said listen johnny you
know loved it we want to have him back
on the show and you know there was an
hour and a half back then so uh big
friday night show so i flew right back
and
said so this tap dancing on the desk
actually happened on live television no
it didn't it was my audition okay
because you because unless you were like
really famous right right you had to go
in there and sort of like i mean carson
you know that was back then when if you
were on carson the next day like
everything changed i mean you launched
seinfeld i mean the list goes on and on
and on don rickles you know all that
stuff was on there and then all of a
sudden like became household name so
um so they said johnny's gonna have them
on he's gonna come out do a quick
interview and he'll probably let him
sing and tap dance one song i had two
prepared but he said just one so i had
to i rehearsed with doc severson in the
band i'll never forget that the floor
was this black lacquer which was really
slippery so heartbroken that they didn't
have you
tap on the desk i know it wasn't so cool
i mean dude so much cooler i know so i
went out there and did my thing and they
said we're gonna do the song and then
talk a little bit and uh apparently the
conversation went really well because
it's it was on like the best of tapes
you know i told him that i was up the
only time i'd seen the shows when i was
up vomiting which is true and i guess
you know johnny with the deadpan to the
audience was just brilliant i didn't
understand any of that but looking back
i do and then uh when i'm vomiting why
would you be up i was sick it was late i
was sick so the only time i was up i
could never see the show i'm thinking
like
my parents were like i was in my parents
room i was vomiting and carson was on
you know as it was in seventy percent of
the households in the united states
trying to have a career in show business
he didn't keep his figure
already yeah but wait so at the time
you're introduced like this is just some
kid he's a great talent he's a great
town you've probably seen him all over
the television on tylenol commercials
and coca-cola commercials and then we
thought we'd have them on have some fun
johnny would do that from time to time
that's great and uh i guess i kicked
butt on the first number so the
interview went so well that afterwards
the proof came i said listen we're gonna
have you talk more and go back out and
do the second song so i was on for like
like 18 minutes which as you know is
unheard of i mean it just doesn't happen
so and joan rivers i guess followed me
out afterwards and when i was done and
they saw me off she came out on her
knees and was like there's no way i can
follow that so the next day
nbc called and said listen we'd love to
sign him and we have a couple of pilots
and so i started doing i did uh a pilot
for nbc with bob denver called scamps
that sherwood schwartz created right
brady bunch
and then and then i did a pilot that was
ron howard's first directing job called
little shots with a bunch of young kids
that went on to do great things and um
finally they put me and give me give me
a break which worked and got picked up
wow so
bob denver i mean i'm just that that
tripped me up because bob denver was at
like a sort of a country musician
country road take me home no no no no
the actor yeah
yeah yeah
john denver john denver yeah
bob denver was gillian you ever see
gilligan bob denver was gilligan
oh gilligan yeah gilligan exactly
gilligan yes so uh i'm sure schwartz did
gilligan's island too right he did he
produced that he was one of those epic
you know producers you know yeah like
norman lear you know did a bunch of
great shows like spelling he's like like
a spelling guy yeah you know had a bunch
of great shows in the in the golden age
of tv you know uh so
they they put me in two piles didn't go
and then they had just shot us a a show
with um a tony award winner nell carter
who was like a triple threat
multi-talented amazing funny lady who
could sing and dance and everything and
she had her own show called give me a
break you know which was groundbreaking
at the time in 1982 and uh they were
gonna add a little carrot a little kid
to it and they and they shot the pilot
and was like we need something before we
go to series and so they put me in that
and that show became a massive hit and
that was kind of how i got my start with
nbc
and you're not shuttling back and forth
between philly and la to do all these
jobs he kind of just made the move i was
believe it or not we did not officially
move we we bought a house here we rented
a house and we bought a house but we
didn't officially move here to like 95.
you know wow what was that law that uh
all that they were talking about yeah
yeah yeah we've had a bunch of people
that talked about that cougar law yeah
the freddie freddie cougar law
your parents are only allowed to blow 85
of your money well that's what's
right yeah we're gonna we're gonna save
20 for you yeah nothing else but no uh
yeah i mean they do that it goes into a
you know a trust account a blocked trust
account certain portion of it well how
were your parents though with managing
their sorry there's like a b in here and
i'm allergic to b so i got the shoe but
here
i um to overstate the obvious but
there's also a b in boner and if you
want to get a serious boner then may i
suggest you try
blue chew tablets because they are
delicious chewable tablets with the same
active ingredient as both viagra and
cialis except they cost only a fraction
of the price and if you ever thought it
might be fun to try these boner tablets
let me assure you it is a hoot i have
the best time with it and you don't have
to go to an awkward visit to the doctor
to get your bluetooth tablets because
all you got to do is go to bluetooth.com
and consult with the medical provider
right there on the site and it's quick
and it's easy and when you use the promo
code stevo you get an entire month's
supply of bluetooth tablets absolutely
for free all you have to pay is five
dollars for shipping again if you ever
thought it might be fun to try some of
these tablets
you were right and you should so go to
bluechew.com use the promo code stevo
and get an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets for free all you got
to pay is five bucks for shipping so hop
on it and have a blast
now let's see what happened with that
bee
there's like a big bee there's a gnarly
bee go get it i hate bees too man
you know what's funny about bees yeah
that's a big deal about bees i love bees
vital to you know everything but here's
the deal they don't leave your ass alone
like you know that theory if you don't
bother it it won't bother you
you're talking to the bee expert right
here hey i've been stung i haven't been
doing [ __ ] i've been sitting there in a
chair yeah look at the bees great these
great become
that bee just stung me i didn't do
anything to that beat nothing i got a
close eye
every time with bees like
if i just chilled nothing happened and
then there's a bee scene in our new
jackass movies
the second those beasts came out they
just started lighting me up really how
many did you guys stung a lot i didn't
do [ __ ] i didn't deserve it i heard it
was a carbon dioxide thing maybe bees
have changed like they've changed
if you get it get it bro but i'm afraid
if i swing at it then he's ah
did he fly out he flew out
dude that was dude that was pretty
awesome
um okay my question is that shoe you
like i know yeah you felt the shoe you
feel it yeah how were your parents with
managing like a child star and the money
my parents were fine with all that you
know i mean it was
what did they do
in their own careers my mother was a
school teacher uh master's degree in
like early childhood development did all
that kind of stuff she taught like third
grade and amazing and then my dad just
sold like insurance so yeah they didn't
and you know this was like out of the
blue that it took off like this so uh
you know the family we sort of every
three weeks my mom school was very
important so i was enrolled in a in a
little believe it or not private like
little quaker school because education
was so good back there was a friends
school back in the east coast the
friends school system is like a really
great school system so yeah babington
friends and georgetown friends and all
these things anyway um so she kept me i
was a lifer there i graduated from there
every three weeks i'd fly back take all
my tests all my friends were from there
it was the greatest thing ever and then
for three years in between give me a
break and blossom she pulled me
completely out of the business except
for commercials and a couple little
movies here and there during the summer
but i had no schedule other than she
wanted me enrolled in middle school she
thought it was paramount for development
you know in relationships and honestly
man it was the greatest three years i'm
so glad i had it because the context i
never got caught up in any of that stuff
it was always like this is my work like
little league baseball that's how we
treated it like traveling teams you know
i got friends dear that they have
children they travel all over the place
my girls were both in in dance leagues
and we traveled to competitions my
parents my mom was the same way she was
like this is how we're gonna treat it so
it was never became my life it just
became something i loved to do um and my
friends all my friends were my school
friends i didn't like i knew everybody
but i didn't have any actor friends you
know like i wouldn't hang out with
anybody i would hang out with my friends
from back east
and the the school was a quaker school
yeah it was a quaker school but it was
just i mean it's probably better because
the experience that we've had talking to
child stars is that there's this weird
phenomenon where
you're a child star you're successful
you're you know talented you're like but
you're you draw all of this bullying and
like yeah you know like it's weird i
mean i got a little bit of that you know
i think that we were you know it wasn't
as highlighted as it is today i think
because of social media it's like a
platform you know not only look there's
always been bullying i mean always i got
you know i got locked you know when i
went when i it's funny later on when i
came back and i was for like seventh and
eighth grade you know sixth seventh
eighth grade the high schoolers you know
i was pretty famous by then so all my
friends i had known them since i was
five most of the kids believing like 80
of my class were lifers so we grew up
and graduated together it was cool
i mean again these things you don't
realize how crazy
wonderful that is and what a blessing
that is but it was amazing so but you
know some of high schoolers i got locked
in the high school bathroom for like
three hours you know
yeah i mean i got you know there was a
little bit of that i got made fun of
cause i'd come back with like doc
martens you know they'd be like wouldn't
it you know and then sure enough but
like two months later once they got to
philly everybody was wearing them you
know everybody was copying me so you
know that stuff happens but i feel like
today there's such a platform for
bullies to be emboldened that there's a
lot more of it because i think that just
like anything else you highlight
somebody's bad behavior and if they're
drawn to that it emboldens them and now
you hear about you know horrible things
but i got a little bit of that how old
were you when you're doing blossom i got
that show when i was uh like 13. so then
you went to high school while you were
on blossom yeah 13 and 19. you had the
long hair yeah is that why you hated the
long hair that's why well i yes because
i didn't mind it until i couldn't change
it you know because that became part of
my character
so yeah so when that was over and you
know and we did brotherly love i cut it
fairly short like the second season of
that show and then when i was done with
that uh i uh right after american dreams
i just buzzed it you know because that
was like i just wanted to do that yeah
everybody thought like britney spears
oh my gosh
oh my god yeah so uh yeah so that was
sort of my thing and then i had shaved
for a while it's such a such a healthy
well-adjusted approach to to your career
is what i'm hearing you know it really
was man i mean look it's always been
look there are ups and downs to
everything i'm still 40 years in i
haven't accomplished anything like a ton
of stuff that i want that i don't want
to and you see people getting shots that
you wish you got it happens everybody
you know and you wonder why and i've
always had to work so hard to like
reestablish things you know some people
they get in that and then they just pop
from one to one you know the next one
the next one you just wow amazing it's
pretty rare it is longevity is pretty
rare it is so for me i've i've been
around a long time but there's been ups
and downs and and i've had to really
really really work to break down a lot
of barriers along the way because you
have that kind of success as a kid it's
great but on the other side of it is you
get typecast a lot and a lot of people
think that you do your job really well i
mean at the end of the day matt leblanc
was basically playing
joey russo right at 25 on friends i mean
a matter of fact they named you know it
was joey tribiani so like nbc knew
exactly what was going on with those two
things um you know as a matter of fact
matt would he i think they had him come
to the stage when they were shooting in
the early development of friends to
watch how i was playing that character
because when you play a dumb character
if he's innocent and he's a womanizer
you can get away with anything because
he's not like a lecherous person so joey
russo got away with a lot of stuff
because he was just innocent you know
like oh my god i love boobs they're
amazing that's not disrespectful because
he's just being genuinely honest you
know right instead of going yeah baby
you know once it gets into that and matt
leblanc did that beautifully at 25. i
was 15. so matt leblanc was you know you
get nominated you know you get nominated
you get golden globes at 15 they just
think oh that must be what he is you
know so coming out of that there's
there's a lot of transition that has to
happen and you have to you break down a
lot of barriers that shouldn't be there
because as actors that's we get paid to
do is play different characters so like
why wouldn't you be able to do that you
know so anyway but it's been great man
i'm still here still doing what i love
to do and still shockingly good looking
man
the secret to the to the fountain of
youtube you're 45. i'll be 46 in april
man i mean jesus like uh have you just
been
have you been uh with the creams and
like the like you know i i've always my
my grandfather was you know he he lived
till 92 would have lived probably to 100
if he hadn't fallen classic case of like
falling and just it going downhill
quickly but he said you get one can what
you put in is you know what you get out
of it so it i i always i was i loved
playing sports and when i was working a
lot and especially on the blossom years
i they didn't want me to play a lot of
the i played football and you know
baseball and i broke my thumb and then
that was it like they don't want me
playing any sports so i started to put
it into like just physical fitness but
like health not not about size not about
like how big can i get not about how
many plates can i put on there it was
always about physical health you know
and if you're fit as a byproduct of
being healthy then that's dope you know
but it was not about like you know and
like these guys like the rock and stuff
they're just so big i mean i i don't
want it that's awesome but that was
never what it was for me you know um so
that's part of it is that i've always
tried to eat really clean um and i and i
and i you know have whatever i want just
in moderation i i don't believe in diets
because i think as soon as you say no
carbs keto this
you're doomed because you got to have
whatever you want if i want cookies i
eat them ice cream pizza i have it all i
just have it in moderation and i eat
good around it you know
yeah we're both like i'm so shameful no
no no
no no no but that's not what i mean
scott wants cookies and ice cream he
eats it
too you guys are on the same side yeah
partially that it's partially genetics
you know my grandfather looked awesome i
mean he looked you know when when he was
90 he looked like 75 you know i mean he
just did i mean so my mom looks great so
i know that's part of it yeah i think
it's jeans because there are people who
just did heroin and cocaine and like and
it just preserved them you know like
that's true it can go one of two ways
all that stuff can preserve you or you
fool around like they always said you
know you you go nuts in your teens in
your 20s and your 30s it like shows up
on your face in your 40s right you're
like oh my god what happened but the
body will disintegrate at some point um
and you know i don't know i just try to
you know i use creams i like creams man
i haven't done you know like the
surgeries i don't i don't really want to
do that i think guys always look you
can't stop once you start well yeah
that's that's the thing like
especially guys like you start messing
around with the eyes and yeah you start
to look different like guys look like
they get this weird like they just
witnessed a murder thing and like it
like this thing like what's happening
why is he looking like that it's like
that's how he always looks now you know
just look old like dudes look good
looking all the time ladies
there's something to be said about a
little bit of preservation but but let
it gracefully sort of happen because
what happens is you get all this plastic
surgery or you get all the fillers and
everything and so many of these even men
or beautiful women they you end up
thinking they're older than they
actually even are you're like wait a
minute why you must be like 60 because
you're getting all this work done
they're only 50. yeah but they
preemptively they they try to prevent it
so much that they end up looking
actually older in a weird way yeah you
know so i don't know yeah i go on dates
with girls and their lips are so big and
they're like 28. it's like what whoa i
think that's like once you start that
once you start it's a slippery slope the
problem is once you start it it goes out
and then like people are getting all
this reconstruction without like the
surgery that stuff freaks me out they're
putting all this goop in there and then
like the goop you've seen horror stories
where like oh yeah it makes a perfect
jawline right and then like six months
later it's in here and then they got
like oh we'll we'll melt that and we'll
put it back in here and then you spend
the rest of your life just becoming like
an experiment you know so girl had me
watching that botched show oh yeah
dude those are really really really
gnarly well he's a plastic surgeon on tv
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah kinda kind of
it's pretty interesting man we've been
we've been doing this podcast for a
while it's introduced us to like so many
interesting people yeah and uh like
when you have a career in show business
for as many decades as you have like
it is very rare to be so
well adjusted oh you're not like it
seems like you've really navigated it
super well and uh yeah especially like
90s you know actors or yeah
i don't think i ever heard about you
having like any sort of uh drug drug
problem
you know man i never never got into the
drug thing honest honest to goodness we
had uh jody sweetin on okay okay okay
corey corey feldman
but i feel like
are you guys a part of like a fraternity
or you know of of like the 90s was a
special time and you guys all had
something to relate to it was you know
it's so weird man it really was like i
said i knew all of them and i know all
of them i just never
ran in those circles i never did it i i
literally i loved my family's i love my
brothers so much we i swear to god i
spent most of my time with them and and
i really did spend the other free time
that i had with my best friends from
philadelphia like chris and and and ryan
and just my guy like my guys that i grew
up with and they would fly out my cousin
neil i would rather them fly out for the
summer and it was true chris would come
out for two weeks you know um neil would
come out for two three weeks and then i
would work a little bit in the summer
and then we'd go on a family vacation
with my brother for two weeks and that
was my summer like and then other than
that i just it was work was my drug like
i love to work still to this day i love
working i love you know the opportunity
to be successful take care everybody i
was i never drinking like i mean yeah
when i was 21 and stuff sure i drank but
i never i never got to that place where
i needed to drink still to this day i
can i i don't need an
alcoholic beverage at all i what i do
need to do is work out i i do feel that
and uh i use a lot of my own body weight
so i can do it at home now which is
great especially since the last two and
a half years of nightmare but uh
push-ups and pull-ups little light
weight on my arms that's it and some
light cardio but honestly like a nice
hike or jumping jacks is all guys need
all this treadmill stuff is
yes
so um
i i really really think that that's
impressive the whole we're gonna treat
this career like little league yeah you
know that's what it was i've never heard
that and i think that that just makes so
much sense and it's probably got a lot
to do with with why you know you stayed
on the right track 100
at the same time though when you're in
high school even middle school aren't
you on the cover of like tiger b
like uh you're like you're like a teen
magazine
talk about an understatement i mean this
guy is still the most throbbing
heartthrob ever i don't think any of us
can expect to look as good as joey
lawrence but what we can expect is to
keep looking as good as we do right now
for much longer if we just take care of
ourselves and what we put in our bodies
now admittedly i don't eat that great of
a diet lately but i don't have to worry
too much because i'm filling in the gaps
in my diet with athletic greens
this stuff is magic it's absolutely
delicious and one serving is loaded with
75 different vitamins and minerals and
probiotics all kinds of healthy whole
food sourced nutrition and it's
absolutely delicious i religiously start
every day with it by dumping one of
these packets into 16 ounces of water
swirling it up and i can do that on a
totally empty stomach unlike all kinds
of other supplements which aren't even
delicious this fills in the gaps in my
diet takes care of my nutrition and it
is delicious plus if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo then with your first purchase you
get five
free travel packs of ag-1 which again is
what i use every morning
plus an entire year supply of immune
boosting vitamin d again that's the deal
that you get if you go to
athleticgreens.com so dude jump on that
deal and let's get back to throbbing
yeah like you're you're you're like a
teenage sex symbol like heartthrob you
had the flannel wrapped around your
waist
yeah you know you look back there was a
decade there where you know uh whenever
i would travel we'd have to travel with
security i really couldn't drive
anywhere you know i was driven which is
by the way so weird i love cars i love
to drive i always love car service i was
like two years old i could i could
literally name a car off like a door
handle i don't know why but i've been
obsessed i collected matchbox cars went
to the borrego models and then you know
big cars when i could do that but um
and uh it was a wild ten years i mean it
was amazing you know we do autograph
signings we go to like paramus new
jersey at a sam goody's there especially
when my first record came out and stuff
and you know like like 30 000 people
would show up now today you would hear
about that in two seconds but back then
you know it took a little while right
that's the kind of crowds i mean we went
to we went to and it was all over it was
all over the world i mean it was not
just here so yeah it was it was really a
tremendous time and yeah but i never
thought about it like it was just weird
i never got caught up in it i was
appreciative of it sometimes i didn't
appreciate it enough actually it was
like exactly kind of what was happening
you know and uh you know um but but i
never i never it never was my life i was
always excited to do the work and then
get done like not deal with it did you
have uh like girlfriends when you were
in that phase i did i did i i i had a
girlfriend you know um for a long time
that i met and then we were to kind of
together for like five years during that
four and a half five years doing that
which was rare and then um and then
dated a little bit and then you know
like look i'm a hopeless romantic so you
know
married the wrong person when i was
young you know like 22 it lasted like
six months 23 lasted six months and then
i got back together with my high school
sweetheart believe it or not and we got
married and then 15 years went by was it
was when we were just we just grew apart
you know unfortunately it makes me sad
but just the way it works and just
realize that's not the right person i
have two beautiful daughters from that
and i love my daughters and you know we
share custody and i see them literally
all the time and every day you know but
uh they are my life and i love them and
i pride myself on being the best dad
that i can be but you know that bums me
out because i wish that would have been
right it just isn't you know my my
parents were married 30 years before
they got divorced i don't know why
but uh it just happens that way
sometimes you know man it just happens
yeah it's a bummer but that's just the
way it works so you know uh definitely
not perfect dude i mean you you know you
make your mistakes and stuff but you
know i tried to mitigate those much
possible i think accountability which
was ingrained in me at a very young age
just taking responsibility for the
things you do
incorrectly
you know that's a big testament to sort
of like realizing like hey man you're
not perfect and i'm far from that so
yeah i think i think there's
accountability and then there's just
plain beating yourself up and i think
you're giving yourself a hard time like
hey dude like relationships don't don't
they just don't yeah
amicable divorce if that's your worst
thing that's pretty good yeah yeah
especially someone in yourself
you know what's crazy is it it really
you
it's this this desire to get married
young and have your kids young it really
is weird because you really you really
have a much better chance of meeting the
right person when you're older because
the pretense is gone and you know you
know who you are and yeah you know
you've grown into who you are and
they've grown into who they are you know
i mean i was lucky enough to meet
finally i think the right person for me
you know about almost two years ago you
know year and year and a half ago pretty
much uh and uh she's amazing you know
and and you just never you realize
nothing is perfect but you realize like
wow when it's right that's what it is
it's like a best friend you always grow
up thinking like opposites attract it's
great that i have my thing and she
doesn't really know about my thing and
i've she has her thing man you actually
want somebody that speaks the same
language has the same sense of humor you
can like be yourself around that when
something's going down like you actually
want to talk to them not like the
specified friends that know who you are
you know because that just divides like
fisher's in a relationship uh she
doesn't get it so i'll talk to him and
then i'll talk to her because they get
it you know and then you're not really
bonding with the very person that you're
supposed to grow old with you know so
it's really a misnomer that i think a
lot of times we get caught up in but uh
i've realized that late you know yeah
so when did the
the music kick in music was believe it
or not first that's what i love which is
why i was able to sing and dance oh
that's why you were tap dancing on time
right and then you had a top 100
billboard it was like top 19 album it
was at top 19 now it was a number it was
number one on on on the the single
nothing my love can't fix was number it
was the number one song and top five on
billboard r r was was radio plays right
and billboard was was sales so it was
top five on billboard number one on r
wow uh it did really well that first
record um classic story happened with
that where just i'll just leave it at
horrible mismanagement by the team and a
lot of stealing and all that stuff that
left a terrible taste in your mouth and
then just kind of got shepherded into
what did you say the team was that the
label yeah it was just a bunch of the
label in my personal music management
and just it was a big mess does it
matter music music management in the 90s
sounds awful it was especially for like
a pop star yeah it's like it was just it
was just a it was just a it was just a
uh an embezzlement scheme waiting to
happen you know if you didn't have the
hawks out and my parents you know they
learned on the fly my mom was not savvy
about any of that stuff so and you know
i i learned the hard way by basically
having every mistake made you know um so
anyway left a bad taste in my mouth we
did the second record but i didn't want
to and it didn't do well and then i just
took a break because i just didn't want
to do it but the first record did super
good so we started releasing music again
about three i've always released every
now and then a little song here and
there but about three years ago
seriously started to release some music
again and it's done really really really
well and
this latest collab i did with matthew
gerard who's a great pop writer he's
written smash hits for everyone from
smash mouth to miley cyrus to kelly
clarkson to everybody he really believed
and we started co-writing some stuff and
this newest stuff that i've been
releasing has been crushing on spotify
and stuff which is weird so all of a
sudden wow
that's interesting
so you see you had success with music in
the 90s out of the game and very much
you know before napster before
so there was just pure money yeah and
then now like you come back and it's a
completely different totally landscape
yeah man and uh it's so weird and you
say it's doing very well now but it is
you do it on streams you know it's just
the barometer of doing well too is like
i mean
you know back then it's like i mean you
you you know a million records was like
good that's pretty good million man way
to go platinum good job you know let's
get to two million let's get to three
million right you sell a million records
i mean you're adele you know like
there's very few people that even go
half a million now i mean i mean it's
crazy right there's very few people and
it's only because people covet the
actual you know physical item otherwise
they wouldn't do it either you know so
once we started giving away music it's
changes everything yeah
you're counting for adele to hit a
million like an itunes purchase like
like that's right it's not just the the
fit
if you only counted the physical cd oh
then that'd be nothing yeah it would be
not going to be mere
fraction yeah but without people
actually purchasing music you're still
getting meaningful revenue from the
spotify you get it but but the volume
has to be
great i mean it has to be millions and
millions of streams how are you
promoting your music to to reach people
are there you know it's such and that's
another crazy thing i mean you do it on
your socials you know uh it goes viral
those those things they take on a life
of their own they're still trying to i
mean look the whole world has been
changing right the last three to five
years has been a complete upheaval of
pretty much everything and it's going to
continue i mean it's it's now look at
what's happening with you know digital
currency and nfts
my brother is obsessed with it my middle
brother matt um he's just a he's been uh
you know diving in deep to all that
stuff i am just like
man i don't know i mean i haven't
brothers yeah we have two i have two
younger brothers yeah two younger matt
you know who uh just turned 42 yesterday
and my brother andrew who's 34 so andrew
is the director he's a director he's the
one that directed uh
the lifetime movie that i met my fiance
on by the way which is crazy because
i've never
ever like worked with someone and like
dated them like never i never did that
and this was crazy because my brother
put together this movie he wrote it and
and i was like okay he asked me to do it
and i said all right and at the last
minute the actress they had set it was
in the middle of covid you know the
actions they had set so we were all i
didn't nobody knew anything you know so
i was like all right let's just be chill
let's just be careful the last minute
she traveled or something and then you
know obviously that was like no we can't
do it so they had to recast i didn't
even have time to i didn't know who was
i was like what i was going on the set
hadn't seen a picture of nothing i was
like andy you're killing me dude if this
is anybody but you like there's no way
i'm doing this no way so i was a little
bit of a brat going in there because my
baby brother and i was like i'm doing
you a solid man i don't even know who
i'm working with and she was your
on-screen romance yes school so yes i
was the bad guy but yes she was i was
the one that was trying to swindle her
money and then she ends up with the
right guy but yes so but it was our
movie yeah so um and uh
day one i come in there you know with
i'm always a pro but i came in there
with like brotherly attitude you know
like
let's do it you know
so you know and the first scene of
course which i was so pissed off was the
scene we were in bed and you know and i
had to like share a bed i'm like this is
ridiculous bro i am so pissed at this
schedule you know he's like just do it
please
you know i swear to god please
and she and she cracks a joke because
she's one of the funniest people that
i've ever met and uh she's like that
what's what's up attitude you know i was
like what who was this you know and lo
and lo and behold man like three weeks
goes by and she's literally the coolest
person i ever met you know and then like
you know in 18 19 20 months later it's
like it's been the greatest 19 months of
my life especially coming out of you
know a tough time you know divorcing you
know divorce is funny people hear
divorce and they see a filing date and
you know that's the end of it you know
they don't realize that two three four
years before then so it's so funny
because so many times they hear like oh
well he got divorced and you know uh or
filed for divorce in june and by you
know november he's dating someone else
and you're like the ink wasn't even dry
right yeah i know you love that it's
like you know so i'm like well wait a
minute first of all november that's like
five and a half months and but more than
that
it's five years i mean you know they
don't see the deterioration and how the
pain and the ups and downs from
everybody involved in that relationship
both sides you know so
that's what kills me but at any rate
it's been the greatest 19 months amazing
i'm very blessed and thankful for that
and the the lifetime but andy direct
that deadly deed he directed that and
wrote that so that was uh so there's a
lifetime movie and that's different from
the amazon movie yes then he put
together we put together a little
christmas film that we sold to amazon
called mistletoe mix up which was my
brother matt had to have the lead in
that i was a supporting character in
that we try to do things together when
we can we actually haven't worked
together we had a big show together
called brotherly love and did a bunch of
tv movies together and then for like
literally 15 17 years you know it's the
classic thing like we couldn't get on
the same page to work together so we
always hung out but you know like we
were doing our own thing so and then you
kind of get to a point you're like i
guess like the jonas brothers like you
know they broke apart right didn't want
to record and then all of a sudden even
after nick had all that success he's
like i kind of would rather just do with
my brothers you know yeah so that's kind
of like what we do is like when it makes
sense we kind of like working together
so we just do it so there was one jonas
brother that was like nick nick broke
out oh nick for sure is that nick for
sure yeah he's been like a judge on the
voice like he's yeah i mean nick had
massive hits by himself now joe jonas
did as well with dnce had a couple of oh
he's never kicked by the ocean and stuff
like that but but nick i mean had like
two
in my opinion i love pop music he had
two great solo records and he did not
like alec baldwin he's nick's like
so he certainly didn't in a business
sense need to go back and record with
his brother it's like justin
i don't know if he'll ever go back
within sync but he certainly doesn't
need to you know right um and nick did
because and i love that i always root
for those guys because i love the fact
they truly do love each other you know i
mean so do my
bros and i we love each other and so
that's why we started working together
again and we said let's just have some
fun man this world's crazy i don't know
and what's going on so during cover
we're like let's just work together you
know and we did it and it was like the
number one
holiday movie on amazon so we're gonna
do a sequel to that which is fun and uh
and then my fiance now was the first
time i've ever done this we wrote a
script together uh romantic comedy in
the vein of like uh you know when harry
met sally like a throwback sort of
dialogue driven rom-com with edge and um
and we sold it to uh toby what was fox
and their streamer toby and we're gonna
shoot it over the summer and i and i and
i had them hire andy to direct it so
super cool that's really cool what was
the dynamic like originally when you
like because you're you're already kind
of famous right and your younger
brothers are like we want to act too
right or yep they're just like we want
to be like joey of course pretty much
don't do it i was like don't do it
you'll never live up to it guys yeah
exactly
massive five foot nine shadows right
right so it wasn't like really
competitive were you like let me help
you guys out how was that i was
basically
doing anything i could you know i never
thought about it as competition you know
um so i i just didn't i mean they i put
them on the shows that i was on and you
know and then they got their own shows
because they you know they were on their
own vehicles because they're really good
yeah uh and uh and we we always did that
was there any like advice you had for
them i mean you had avoided a lot of
trappings by example i just left by
example you know uh and my brothers are
a little rowdier than i am you know but
i i i always leave like out of here yeah
oh yeah andy's like andy's like the
rocket the rock and roll guy you know
and you know yeah so uh they always uh
you know they they uh yeah they were
just a little more rambunctious than me
you know but i was like grandpa joe i
don't know why you know but i just never
i was always into sports and just i
don't know man school and working i love
to work i love to be clear-headed i i
never liked rolling onto a set like out
of my mind i would see it so many times
for my peers just going like how are you
going to function today bro what how
late were you up what were you doing you
know so for me even to this day like
when i have if i have a 7 am call i'm up
at four i take a shower workout eat
breakfast and then i come to set i'm i'm
ready i don't need to like make me
somebody before i could
i just never approached it that way you
know so it's like a sports thing you got
to be prepared right so that's where i
come from we've had a ton of dancing
with the stars alumni okay and you guys
are both uh dancing with the stars
alumni it's great yeah that's right dude
i was on there that's right dude what
year did you do i did it it was six
three
it was a massive season because it was
just you know that was i mean the
ratings were insane that year right i
think they were getting like 20 they're
averaging 20 million or something like
that episode smith it was emmett and
mario and i turned into mario lopez and
i turned into this
like like dance
it was like a trio and we were all
really competitive i think the first
week like we got we got triple tens like
consecutively week after week after week
after each other so it was like i think
mario did it first and then i did it
then emma did it and then it was on so
we all got to the finals and then emmett
won you know but
it was it turned into this massive thing
so you know they they still do the
dancing with the stars tours but they're
much diminished from i mean we went on a
stadium tour so when i toured it was and
it was myself and joey fatone and drew
lachey and joey mcintyre and emmett and
we literally i mean we sold out staples
center for three nights wow so that's
how big the tour was [ __ ] i had a bus
that was believing that the bus that
they that i got to travel around in we
shot our own buses i mean i didn't i had
never done anything like this because
even when i toured for my music i had to
do it by plane because i was doing show
my show so i could never go on like a
tour so i flew over to london and i tore
and i flew but i never did like the bus
tour sounds like oh man they built a bus
i guess for jennifer lopez right this
crazy cool bus she i guess then got
pregnant like postponed her tour for a
minute so i got this brand new like
multi-million dollar bus
first
it was yeah it was crazy dude like i
mean flat screens it was it i never i
actually and they put us they treated us
so good but they we always stayed like
whatever the best hotel was there were
so many nights where even if there was
like a four season there i was like i'm
just gonna stay on my bus dude that's
what i did
yeah why would i get out of my bus like
i love it i showered i got my tv on you
know i don't need it so
18 months on and off we toured and it
was the coolest 18 months it was so much
fun dude and the show is like you would
come out and do a dance or something
yeah so basically what we do is
we'd each have our solo dances that were
like fan favorites and then we'd have
group numbers solo dances but with your
partners with our partners right right
so mine was edited slowinsco was not on
the show anymore but she was fantastic
um and we we intermittently they would
like stagger our things you know and we
would and we would come out and we would
uh scam likely
scam likely it should be scam definitely
so we would come out and they'd like
stagger us so i do my my solo number and
then
and then we'd have like a group number
with the three of us which no one had
ever seen before and then they have
company numbers we had ray chu and a
crew that was our band we had like a
massive it was like a pop tour it was
not we had rigs they we had 18 trucks
they loaded us in i mean it was like a
bieber tour it was that big and i gotta
believe that the uh the tour was for you
far more lucrative than being on the
show way more yeah back then
they were it was okay but they
exponentially they've realized to get
talent they have to pay a lot more you
know back but the tour
we knew what had happened so the more
they're paying then still the numbers
are going to go down i think that's
weird
yeah i got in pretty early i was on
dancing on the stars uh with um what
season were you on i i was on dancing
with the stars in 2009 okay so you got
in early because i was in six yeah so
you were like season six yeah seven
right um so we got new music coming out
we're gonna we're gonna let everybody
know about this cool yeah where can they
get it well they can get it everywhere
they can get it on spotify they can get
it on itunes um they can get it on
amazon music um they're typing in jayla
they type in joey lawrence
yeah yeah let's get your jayla yeah seo
number well i said one day i've been
asked this question you ever gonna do
with jennifer lawrence i said i love the
movie with jennifer lawrence because
literally they said the the poster's got
to be j law just one jayla or just one
just j-law and then just arrows yeah so
uh but yeah so you can get it every
everywhere um we've released a lot of
singles and guilty which is this little
five song lp that i did with matthew
gerard is is going to be coming out in
its entirety uh at the end of february
so cool yeah do you um
are you the one putting like
that presumably you have music videos
we actually you know it's a weird thing
because you don't really need music
videos we had to see how it was going to
do so i think we're going to record i'm
going in actually next week to record a
brand new song with matthew that i that
i wrote with him called [ __ ] which
is going to be i know it's bs but
[ __ ] is the name and it's it's i've
never done anything like that but it
just it it's a cool little vibe that's
the edgiest thing you've ever done in
your career
yes yeah yeah and it's called bs yeah
you know man it's just so great for me i
mean like you know it's just such a
crazy thing to gr
the the the the amount of expletives in
music today is
i know i sound a hundred but it's
mind-blowing i have two daughters you
know i have a right i have an almost
six-year-old daughter and and a almost
12 year old daughter
i mean dude like
like i grew up you know i mean it is
nothing like ludicrous and snoop and i
mean it is nothing compared to those
guys that i grew up with i mean it is it
is astounding i mean like the ghetto
boys were pretty yeah they were but i
mean this was but i think it's the
actual i think it's the sentiment it's
not nearly to say the words i'm not i'm
not i look i'm from east coast i mean i
grew up on sets i got a mouth like a
trucker but but it's it's the actual
sentiment it's not really the words edge
is great you know like go [ __ ] yourself
what i'm cool with that but it's the the
way they speak especially since i have
daughters like i'm just like oh my god i
mean some of these lyrics are right
astoundingly wild that that would be and
then these little girls are singing them
yeah i always tell
do you hear what you're singing yeah
they panned when the
whoever did the the wet ass [ __ ] song
and then you pan to the audience and
it's like nine year old girls and
they're singing with their mom
and i'm cool but like at some point
you're going like
wow like how the [ __ ] right how does the
[ __ ]
i mean wow that is that's crazy because
like i'm i'm all for you know like like
i mean i grew up in a house full of
women so i'm you know and i mean i
raised a house full of women so my
mother was like the dominant figure in
my house so strong women is amazing but
i'm like how does this sort of lend
itself to that whole
narrative i remember all women support
respect and then like wow it's crazy
right you know look it's not for me to
say they can do what they want obviously
and they haven't done success with it
and they're really catchy so i get it
but boy do i i fall into that old dad
fart vibe where i'm like hey what the
hell is no no no no no no
nope so they have like dad's playlist
now where they go i gotta skip this one
because you're not gonna let me play it
i'm like you're right am i going to play
my car but i don't think they'll like
before when they're older they hate me
you know they they they don't think it's
cool now but so many times my parents or
my grandparents especially my
grandfather did things i was like man
what and but when i grew up i was like
wow dude you were so right i remember i
remember we bought the chronic uh a 92
album and like my dad saw it and he's
like the marijuana leaf and then he's
like and it's parental advisory and he
threw in the trash you know it's like i
know i grew up when the parental
advisory meant something right
of course do you know that i i had a
very similar experience like that
because a buddy of mine turned me on to
andrew dice clay okay in seventh grade
when he had that sentiment there dice
don't hurt him right and little boy blue
he needed the money right i still know
them all
i literally could do them all for you
right now anyway so in seventh grade i'm
back in school right fully submerged
right in school and we're going on a
coal country trip because philadelphia
we're gonna go to coal country overnight
trip and my buddy ross no joke i don't
even know where ross is i lost touch
without i don't know ross but he was a
good friend of mine in seventh grade and
he's on the bus ride we got a three hour
bus ride he goes hey joey i'm like yeah
he's like you heard this new comedian
i'm like no but i love comedy you know
he's like great he's like listen to this
and for three hours dude i memorized
that entire both sides of that team okay
when he was like what the [ __ ] so some
chick was talking about you know i mean
it's like i mean [ __ ] you [ __ ] ball you
know this whole thing little bow pete
[ __ ] a sheep blew a horse licked his
feet shaved his ass so every nice
tongued his balls not once but twice
anyway i'm going to embarrass everybody
that's listening especially my family my
family oh god they're still doing my
brother's not like joe really shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah um anyway so i get home and my dad
picks me up from the bus stop i swear to
god and he's like my dad loved comedy so
i was like dad he's like how the trip
was great was great but guess what i
found this new comedian he's like no way
i'm like yeah like can we go to sam
goody's like i'm taking my son to get a
comedy tape absolutely because he always
tried to get me listen like george carl
and stuff but i i didn't get it so and
that meant george carl's amazing but at
12 i was like i don't sure it's okay you
know i like eddie murphy and stuff you
know so he was like great let's do it
comedy fantastic so we go in there
andrew nice clean this sounds great so
he puts it in i swear to god in the
first line he's like die stud he's like
so i was [ __ ] some chick that goes
okay what the [ __ ] what is this
i swear to god no nope nope you pop the
thing out just what your dad did he's
like absolutely not that's it yeah wow
yeah but still to this day i remember i
know it oh yeah but he's like sitting
there like can't we just listen to
carlin which is also like it is dirty
but you know but again it was like a
whole new dice was a whole new he was a
whole new level
yeah right right yes that's like the
wettest [ __ ] of his day he was yeah
right he was and you're like girls can't
we just put them i know song or
something you know you become your
parents yeah when you have children i
think you do it's not that i'm like my
parents i mean i am in certain regards
but the ch my kid like i just go and you
know you become like a fart man like
like a fart and i i try not to be i
think i'm pretty cool in a lot of ways
but that stuff i just feel like it's my
duty to just at least say this is
inappropriate you know right at least
give them that yeah yep and i do i mean
they listen to it i don't like ban it
but i just go this is just listen all
i'm asking is just really take in what
they're saying here right yeah great
beat i don't care you know i think there
are a lot of
like child stars and and kind of stars
in general
whose
work is like
very clean and family friendly but the
the
stars themselves are not yeah
yeah i was gonna say yeah yeah and
it seems like uh
i i really get the sense that that your
the work you did in your career was all
very family friendly and that that's
genuinely who you were yeah in your life
yeah i am look man i mean yes really i
love that yeah i'm not i don't i don't
have that underbelly side you know kind
of what you see is what you get like i
said i'm not a perfect guy you know i i
got drunk off my ass a lot in my 20s but
i never got involved in those situations
where it went too far you know um i
always had an awareness my mom told me
what you put into your think about it
has nothing to do with me if you're
these parties and there's drugs flowing
around a lot if you do that to you
there's a chance that you can die i love
you i don't want it to happen but you're
not doing it for me you're doing it for
you and that struck such a cord to me
and i don't know what it was but when it
was presented to me and there were
several opportunities where i was you
know and rampantly obviously you know
being famous and as famous as i was and
you know it was everywhere you know and
i just was like i got actually off on
saying no i really did i don't need bro
get out of my dude have fun i'm not
doing it i'm not doing it and i just
because i wanted to go to the gym in the
morning i didn't want to screw up my gym
schedule i didn't want to mess up my
work schedule i was you know
getting up and driving my brother to
school and then driving to the set and
you know doing my work and then you know
i would get it working in on the on the
lunch break you know so like
i just did that being a
heart on the cover of heartthrob
magazines just the opportunity to act
out sexually that you had yeah and you
didn't take advice
i mean that's where i kind of feel mad
at you well and you know what my best
buddy does too dave if you're listening
he's like man we became best friends at
about i was like about 17 or eight i was
actually i was about 18 right and he was
like my god if i just met you five years
ago you know and yeah uh but you know he
uh he comes over he's like let's get
[ __ ] up and get some [ __ ] you're like
nah i didn't want to just like
dude
uh no look look i mean look there was
there was there was opportunity you know
uh you know there was some fun that i
had for sure but i never i never i mean
there was you know there was amazing
experiences that i was able to have
where i'm like i cannot believe this
person like likes me you know i can't
believe i'm kissing this person but you
know it's just i mean i never it never
got out of control let me just put it
that way i never it was never in a
situation where i allowed myself to just
be out of control i didn't know what i
was doing i always wanted to be aware of
what i was doing yeah like scott and i
for sure probably not paul but scott and
i we're we're that we're like we're both
sober alcoholics we're both like you
know
super like you
know crazy histories of acting out
sexually and i think that the dynamic
for for us and for you know a lot of
guys if not most guys is that you know
there's something about the conquest of
a sexual conquest then where it's that
that validates you i know you're not
that valuable finding your identity yeah
like that it's all right if you get so
wrong if you can hook up with a chick
then that then that somehow boosts your
self-worth when in reality
like having like promiscuous sexual
encounters does not increase one's
self-worth it depletes it you know and
and it seems that like the more you act
out trying to validate yourself you're
actually just driving
you know you're
you're digging deeper and deeper into a
hole yeah like what what girl wants to
[Applause]
live happily ever after with the guy who
humped 500 chicks you know like and and
that's that's where
guys are considering that validation
yeah and it sounds like you just
scott and i were not secure
in who we were you know like we had very
we were very insecure and that's why we
wanted to act out right and i just get
the sense again that that you were very
secure in who you were and you didn't
need to do that i think so i was very
secure in that area for sure you know
when it came to being unfortunately
being on tv and doing everything i over
analyzed myself a lot you know like i
get insecure about my actual self you
know like you know is is my hair okay or
are the eyebrows too much is the beard
too much your hair is just fine no but i
mean you're perfect but no but no but no
but no but i would i would always get i
would always get really really insecure
about that you know um so i think i took
it on myself like about how i looked my
my first my personal being was where the
clothes okay everything like that
it never but i and and that i obsessed
over you know i was worried about more
than about being you know like you know
perfect or trying to be okay or close to
perfect you know which is impossible and
nobody should be and actually it's much
more attractive to not be perfect you
know so but i think that because i
started so young and i was in a system
where
you you were in a grind man but coming
out of the 80s 90s it was like there was
no get out of jail free card and nobody
you know gave you like puppies when you
were upset you know what i mean like if
you didn't do your job you were fired
you know like and there's a brutality to
that but i don't think going as far as
we've gone on the other side which is
being too soft is good either there's a
middle ground which is great you got to
be accountable you got to take
responsibility for your actions
everything is not somebody else's fault
you know if you don't step up there's
the world is if you don't do your job
and you work for a boss and he he thinks
or she thinks some way you have to step
in line with that you work for them now
maybe one day you'll be the boss right
but this thing like i can do what i want
even though i work for you that didn't
fly when i was growing up i mean you got
fired you know so that to me i think i
then took it personally and was like i
gotta be perfect all the time and that's
where i became insecure but not with not
with right yeah you know yeah not with
like notches on your belt or whatever
that old horrible thing is you know to
like to to to like make myself feel
better about myself you know my my
self-worth came from just the kind of
work i did if i felt good about it and
the way i treated my family and and the
way i treated my friends you know that's
where my school the ownership you talk a
lot about like ownership and the way
your mom put like drug use she was like
don't do it for me it's like yeah it's
you it's you your decision you'll just
oh you're only hurting yourself tell me
so many things about that stuff even
like sharing food and stuff you know you
wanna you wanna get cold sores go ahead
man you know suck down all the you know
you want to swap spit god knows what
you're going to get mouths one of the
dirtiest things on the planet you know
so i was like but you know and for me it
was like yeah like you really want to
know somebody so that you can ask
questions you know like hey you know uh
you have any weird like mouth [ __ ] going
on you know because i really like you
you know instead of just going just
diving in and going like two weeks later
like what the [ __ ] is it oh my you know
yeah like i was so worried about that
[ __ ] you know so yeah
scott and i were like ask no questions
act out as much as possible and then be
like in the grips of terror over what
have i done yeah and you know and i'm a
german
i had friends like that yeah but i had
friends that would call me crying going
like i don't know what the [ __ ] dude i
know i'm getting something and you know
more times than not they didn't but like
there were a few times my friends were
like oh [ __ ] you know in it
unfortunately look everybody goes
through their own things but that's the
journey of life and that's what it is
but man if you can prevent some of it
like prevent it try you know do your
best yes
well i i know we gotta let you go dude
let's uh promote some stuff for you we
gotta bring out the socials let's let
them know what that is yeah i am uh well
it's at joey lawrence on uh instagram
and twitter and i actually uh joey
lawrence on tick tock because i just
started wow nice i just brand my my
daughter's like dad well you got to do
it and so i was like all right i'll try
so we put up a couple brand new things
on tick tock uh and uh yeah you know
look the socials are doing all right i i
have a very loyal fan base as you know
it's like these numbers they're so
bloviated so many times you hear these
numbers like oh 50 million you know 80
million but you look at engagements
they'll like put something out right
like nobody cares so you know i got like
i got like you know like 400 000 on
facebook i have like you know 250 000 on
ig i got you know you know that's what
it twitter's another like 350 000 but
like when we put out a single like you
know 85 000 downloads so like people are
my fans are really really really engaged
because i never hired a company to do it
it was all myself i haven't been doing
it that long and it's growing now
exponentially i think because i'm
talking about it and like putting up
videos my my lady is great with that
she's helping me do that because i never
showed any other like i was always
afraid to like be myself on that thing
be stupid and
just be goofy and i'd love to mess
around and just do dancing and you know
so
did you break out the tap shoes yeah i'm
gonna do that yes i'm gonna do that
it's gotta be honest re-enacted do you
have like uh do you have an old clip of
it there's nothing and then i'll take
talk dude
nobody from the audition
audition man i wish i did but nobody
nobody nobody did it was actually the
29th anniversary of my first number one
hit coming out it was uh two it was on
the ninth so just for the hell of it
like we intercut i put on tick tock we
undercut a little bit my actual music
video that was on and then i recreated
that now just for a second but as myself
yeah and it did super great it did
amazing so anyway stuff like that's fun
and just letting people know because
even though i've been around a long time
they very few people know about actually
my personal
stuff they don't really know you know i
was old school you kept that in private
so i'm just now sort of embracing the
fact that i can be you know a little
more uh you know vulnerable and sort of
expose some of that stuff that i feel
comfortable with you know yeah and i
would encourage you to make music videos
too i'm going to i know that is
something i think for bs we're going to
actually which will be especially with
the director brother yeah i know you
know no we're going to we this was a
test run a lot of people invested you
know um you know matthew invested a lot
to bring this to life and i think he
wanted to see if it had some legs and
it's got legs so now is like phase two
that's what we just did in five song uh
and now we're gonna do five or five more
yeah smart and uh you know the christmas
movie yeah mistletoe mix-up is still on
amazon it's gonna be great uh frankie
meets jack will be on to be next year uh
and uh we're doing a brand new series
which i i will only say that it's really
exciting it's it's the team from the
wedding crashers which i've always loved
uh and uh it is a back with the brothers
again you know but has grown ass men uh
for the first time in 20 years wow and
it's single camera and it is
super super good man it's really funny
and really edgy and i think people are
going to be but yet we're not like it's
it's very vulnerable and edgy and funny
all at the same time
this is scott randolph and i wouldn't
say the gorgeous paul briskey but with
the man
wow
brother truly thanks for the opportunity
man
there it is dude i really liked joey
lawrence man and um i wonder should i
just say that next week
we know it's going to be
his most famous co-star
i said it i said it
we might have the host of jeopardy
is that too
much i mean that gave it away completely
but that's cool
you were doing it
yeah okay we're riding it we're riding
with it dude i'm in a good mood i'm just
gonna i'm gonna rock it and uh
what can i say dude as i sit here it's
the night before
this comes out and that is thursday
march 10th which is the night of the
biggest show of my life dude i'm so
stoked i'm nervous
i'm going to be in a 1500 seat theater
with people in the audience like
spike jones
like a knoxville like my people
bunch of celebrities industry executives
woof
it's time for me to flex
like how far i've come in this uh live
comedy game
so if you're in la and you're
it's thursday dude
if i can try and squeeze in there
get in there dude baby come on thanks
dudes